James Madison was ever like [ __ ]
fluting and then he's gonna like scratch
his bowl
yeah what how different is that to
twerking you know
[Music]
white people are losing it right now
losing we're losing our [ __ ] mouth
what is what is the all-white table have
to say so so here's what's going on
right now and I need I'm gonna need your
guys you guys to be respectful of my
rage and I need you guys to understand
what the problem is
[ __ ] Catholic gratitude closed
erawan's closed down
um so so lizzo
um made history last week when she
played the flute right presidents James
Madison's Crystal flute that's tight and
yeah I'm pretty upset about it
pretty [ __ ] upset yeah I'm sorry we
haven't been sensitive enough towards
you yeah can we can we understand like
why you're upset about it well you know
apparently like this is a pretty big
deal
and then um she probably shouldn't get
to use it
what was
why why did she play the flute why did
she play his flu specifically yeah uh to
pissed me off is there anyone you think
is sanctioned to play such a flute Kenny
G Katie link Katie Lang okay yeah did
she play it well
it doesn't matter oh I don't know I
didn't listen to it I just read the
article and I was really fuming pissed
apparently lizzo plays flew pretty well
apparently yeah she does she actually
really does She's Tight I think what
people are mad about is um she's working
the whole team yeah at the end of it she
twerked with it and I think you're
twerking with like a historical artifact
or something so it feels like you're
desecrated she put it between her butt
cheeks like yeah she was like this and
then at the end she like
that did she put him between her butt
cheeks no not that I'm not the video
that I saw I think what does it have to
do with the flu
and she just works with it yeah I think
it's fine Indiana Jones twerked a little
when he drank from the Goblet and he
whips he twerks a little bit dude
James Madison was ever like [ __ ]
fluting and then he's gonna like scratch
his balls
yeah what how different is that to
twerking you know
they didn't even have toilet paper back
then he's probably scratching his
[ __ ] ass big time he's like oh my God
epidemic back then they just had
different Customs man yeah it's just
different different things were
appropriate at different times it also
it's lizzo it's it's that's why I want
to know exactly what the purpose of this
uh performance was I think I think it's
just to get under their skin yeah just
to piss me off just to piss off the
whites I think there's like some sort of
curator or whatever at the White House
[ __ ] Jose White House thing Hall of
instruments or something yes and then
did they find out that lizzo played
fluid hey come down and play any flute
you want and then I think she said I
want to play why did that one like why
did she play Grover Cleveland's electric
guitar that's tight why does the White
House need a hall of instruments they
just got Halls of [ __ ] like a museum
that's why the White House has to have
less Halls they have to have less stuff
we gotta fix the problem at the source
yeah she's just exposing it yeah less
halls in the white house too many soft
costs are going to this we'll solve
twerking you and me we're paying for it
dude I think we just exist already no
not the artifacts but to keep them
housed and keep them in nice shiny glass
cases that costs money they need to get
rid of that I think what pisses me off
is I didn't even know that this flute
existed I didn't know either but then
once I knew it existed then I got pissed
James Madison's kind of a plus yeah it's
called retrospective respect yeah what a
loser James Madison playing the flute
like pick a better instrument pick a way
better instrument what what tune did she
play yeah is there a clip of her playing
the flute that we could like she played
wet ass [ __ ]
she didn't even play her own track
that's very
I would play it but I don't even know if
YouTube will be nice to us or whatever
probably not no no no I don't need to
it's okay we'll listen to it again
too yeah I'm a fan I watched her for uh
New Year's uh at the of your babysitter
in Vegas at whatever hotel that I forget
it was but she was I remember going
because uh Nina like loves lizzo and
she's like oh we got these tickets I was
like okay great what song is good by her
because none of the songs really like
is good maybe I'm not listening to the
right ones juice I like all of them so
[ __ ] dope running it down right now I
ain't [ __ ] around just listen to her
top five she should probably do juice
and flute version and she's a really
really charismatic and great performer
and that's why she's great hell yeah I
do the Christmas to the roof yeah
through Matthew McConaughey she really
shakes it she shakes it up okay do we
have videos of her shaking it up I do
have videos I think James Madison should
be like thankful that his flute was you
know like
go girl James Madison a bit down go girl
you go girl what year was James Madison
president you go Glen CoCo nobody knows
all right 17 1800s 19. I looked it up
and nobody knows yeah everyone's like
James Madison was the president honestly
it's probably 1808 to 1812. look it up
um that was incorrect but also by 1864.
just keep going he's not even on a
[ __ ] currency this guy's whacked yeah
who cares Madison on a currency you know
why because you play the flute is he on
a [ __ ] dime or a [ __ ] I think he's
on one of those weird bills James
Madison was President 1809 to 1817. I
said 1808 he's not even on 20 bill that
wasn't it he's got a 50 Bill if they
were Asian yeah he's on a weird one five
thousand dollar bill
it's true holy [ __ ] I sound like a
[ __ ] run but yeah yeah it's hard to
see but okay let's see her get down oh
that's not the clip I saw
the clip I saw was in the White House
well she was in the um like she was
testing it out or something she was
invited by Montpelier which is like I
don't know his [ __ ] house or
something not pillar
Montpelier I think it is but um yeah no
there's a clip of that as well you know
what's the crazy [ __ ] how some
instruments are like millions of dollars
oh that's you know what I mean she
torture yeah that's lit
people always get mad at her about
something
crushed it she's so nice though but Yo
Yo Ma played a historic cello no one
bats tonight yeah yeah yeah
it's like totally the right wheelhouse
he's sick have you ever heard him he's
not sick
he's dope because it's like the way he
shakes his hand I'm like whoa this is
cool more like yo yeah yo he's
subjectively amazing yeah who's your
favorite musician since you're like a
Musician musician Kenny G bro really no
um Bruce Hornsby is the one I like who's
Bruce Hornsby what does he do uh he did
that you know that song uh you know
Tupac Changes the song that he samples
he's the original Dude to do that yeah
dude I just found that Coolio down I
didn't even know
RP Gangster's Paradise that's all it's
like the goat song though it's like a
[ __ ] like imagine imagine if that's
all you did is like Gangster's Paradise
sorry I only did gangsters you know
what's crazy about that top top five
karaoke songs of all time yeah yeah for
some reason it's always it always has to
go down that and Nickelback I don't know
why it's because your friends suck
I think at some point Amish Paradise
kind of edged out uh Gangster's Paradise
a little bit
but only because
Gangster's Paradise was so good you know
that's the reason why
is this like a double jeopardy thing if
Liz is going to get [ __ ] for it anyway
she might as well do some fun things
exactly she's gonna get [ __ ] for it so
like instead of just where she might as
well stuff that thing between her cheeks
and start shaking those things up oh
really
do you think if Josh Groban played it
anyone would give a [ __ ] not because
Josh Groban's not edgy enough he's not
he doesn't push the he doesn't move the
needle hey I'm a fan of Josh going okay
my mom likes him he's great for during
Christmas for Christmas only Christmas
Christmas is all year round
yeah oh Jesus is it no only if you're
Mariah Carey on tour right yeah dude
Josh grew up in sick though I'm a big
fan I like Polar Express do you think
Mike Pence shoved this thing up his ass
people would people be like I get it
that's kind of cool
yeah because I'd be like good for you
like yeah my pencil is my guy I could
shove that thing all the way up his ass
if he wants to would you like that he's
an American he could do whatever he
wants exactly what if it's like David
Blaine or something like that shoves it
up his ass makes you disappear what if
Hulk Hogan slammed on it and broke it in
half oh no don't break it with a leg
drop though the best thing about David
Blaine shoving is up his ass is that he
would do it he would like just keep on
Staring at you while you David Blaine
that's what I'm saying that's really
good I could picture him shove it all
the way up his ass for sure while he's
in like an igloo yeah dude I finally saw
that clip of him swallowing the Frog oh
yeah and I was like but why it's a magic
trick you dummy
what were you waiting for not even not
even why but like how did he figure out
he could do that it's a technique that
he learned about like he had to like
practice it with like water and stuff
first for like months yeah where you can
like drink gallons of water and then
like spew it back out with the Frog yeah
you ever met anybody that could uh
squirt water out of their eye yeah I met
someone that they could do that really
yeah they just learned how to do that I
think that's more impressive than
swallowing a frog
do you think over those months a bunch
of times he's like he's like all right
now let's get this [ __ ] out he's like ah
[ __ ] I don't think it's gonna go do you
think a frog died he had to kill at
least once definitely at least one
definitely have you ever met a person
that can do this thing where they
they'll go hang on they'll go
and then go oh and like Vapor comes out
yeah yeah that's like a real [ __ ]
trick but it's like people like know how
to do this thing where they like go I
don't know what they're [ __ ] doing
but but I met a dude who could do two
amazing things that was one of them
because he just went and like a bunch of
like it looks like smoke but it's just
like air and then the other thing he can
do is he could go like this and like
grab his arm and let go and it's still
pushed down oh I was like the [ __ ] are
you that's not a trick that's like
jaundice or something yeah
that's why it might be attributed to a
disease but I've always asked people
that because I want to know if there's
another dude I just want to be like that
guy like Ryan's like Ryan's like I've
met a guy who could do two amazing
things yeah yeah that's so cool he
showed us in Banana Bay but like it's
like hey you guys want to see some
squishy [ __ ] yeah that's he was
literally that guy it was like I was in
high school he was like hey check this
out and he did this thing but
oh and it just [ __ ] like he was out
of Vape you know what the trick was he
hit an inhaler really quick first and
then he did that
I've seen people do that really that's
you've seen them do that don't you hear
that
but he's probably sneaky that's his
party he's like the Grim Reaper dude but
he's just he's just talking like normal
and then he'll he can do it anytime you
want anytime there's got to be [ __ ]
like explain that [ __ ] in the comments
please explain that [ __ ] because that's
a real trick and I really don't know how
you do it I know a guy who could do I
know a guy who knows a guy who and this
is probably an iron deficiency or some
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]